I reject nation I'm Greg Alba actually
no it means iron fist I got idea Danny
Rand the immortal I am pissed I gotta do
it I just got to do it so there's an
official trailer for Iron Fist season 2
yay
John I've still need to finish Jessica
Jones in season 2 episodes left I'm one
episode away from finishing Luke Cage
season 2 which had a pretty fun
appearance by the daniel rant in there
real quick we do full a TV show
reactions over at our patreon weekly Q&A
s and such a whole bunch of goodies and
one of the reward tiers is a shout-out
and today's shout out is gonna go out to
none other than a Delia Chamberlain
wanted to shout you out in this video
specifically because you actually watch
the Marvel shows this woman is a very
talented writer she actually sent me
over a short story that I have to read
it's on my desktop I'm looking at it
right now and I have to read it I
promise I'll get back to you soon she's
one of the people that I'm constantly in
messages with we really get into some
heavy communication I got to tell you
that you have been one of the highlights
of having a patreon page because getting
to know someone like you who lives all
the way at another state that is so far
away but it feels like you have become a
real friend of ours especially to me so
I'm just wanting to say I'm really
grateful to know you my dear thank you
so much for being a part of our patreon
page and thank you so much for being you
you're the best any here let's watch the
season 2 trailer for this show that
everyone thought was the best and has
the best actor out of all of them I have
hopes for this one
you know not at home in days
really sleep when you are home Oh
many times a night you like that [ __ ]
stuff I see how much you're pushing
yourself just trying to keep the peace
it already looks kind of better actually
as for the article
what are you fighting for
[Music]
we just released
oh it's like so much better than mine
you will suffer
there's like the steel serpent in this
one can't save everyone
I can't just sit here do nothing
I've become sick
to be
three doesn't decide what happens next
yeah we do
[Music]
they're out of movie
no better fight at a restaurant gotta
have it oh god I really hope that is not
just a good trip this actually got me
really excited this looks so much better
I just worry that the trailer is better
than the actual show cuz I remember I
saw the trailer for the first season and
I was like it looks alright maybe the
show is gonna be better and then the
show is whatever I liked the show
honestly it is like the bottom of them
all that this looks like a major
improvement Davos as the villain I'm not
gonna try to [ __ ] you guys as if I
know the Iron Fist comics and whatnot
but I have heard about how Davos is the
steel serpent in the comics it looks
like it's doing that he has his own iron
fist hand in this trailer what they
established with season 1 and having him
be the primary villain in season 2 makes
for an extremely personal villain
because he was already a pretty personal
antagonist in season 1 him as the
defining villain in season 2 if the
fight scenes that they're teasing here
from when they're back at come one he
has the iron fist mask on that just
looks so sweet I got really excited to
see that image because a big part of the
letdown of season one you don't see the
flashback so you don't get actually see
a lot of those things that the other
Marvel shows on Netflix have done where
there's usually an episode dedicated to
seeing some of the origin you just hear
a lot about it but you don't really see
much of it and we're actually gonna get
a see that rivalry of where it's stem
from it looks like that's gonna be an
awesome fight in terms of the fight
choreography it looks much better I
heard that they had the Black Panther
fight choreographer work on the fights
for here hey it seems like Finn Jones's
fighting skills have improved the
choreography just looks a lot better I'm
yet to see something where I'm
completely sold that it's like daredevil
caliber of fight scenes everywhere
around it looks like a major improvement
the Marvel Netflix shows usually have a
rather deliberate pacing about them they
really take their time and I appreciate
that but it seems like they're gonna
really be picking up the steam here I
felt like season 1 kind of had a bland
color palette about it and not that this
trailer is flashing with colors but it
seems like the cinematography has more
style to it one of my favorite episodes
out of Luke Cage season 2 the episode
when
and I want to spoil things in case you
haven't seen it basically Colleen wing
and Misty night they have a pretty bomb
fight scene at a bar and it's you know
teasing that development of daughters of
the Dragon and and their chemistry
together I think is solid watching them
together in Luke a season two got me so
excited so seeing her here is awesome I
want to put this out there really quick
I think a lot of these comic book shows
e on the marble ones I I think there's a
couple of performances in Gotham even
that have if not Golden Globe worthy of
being nominated I think at least Emmy
nominated at a Luke Cage misty knight
who I don't know the actresses name I
feel terrible front knowing it well I
don't feel terrible I just don't know
but misty Knight I think her performance
is totally at least Emmy nomination
worthy honestly I'm more excited to see
misty Knight and Iron Fist season two
with Colleen wing and I am if they were
to tease Luke Cage making a cameo here
which I would like for him to make a
cameo here but I wouldn't wanting to be
a character that runs throughout the
season I would like misty Knight to be a
character that is in here throughout the
season I noticed the trailers are still
not showing us much of Finn Jones acting
I'm one of those people who thinks Finn
Jones is like amusing to watch it Hayes
entered a you know what you know in
terms of like the emotional depth scenes
I hope he can really deliver on that in
this season and I also like this
approach that Marvel's been doing with
their shows especially in their in their
second seasons as having the main
characters fight someone with equal
skills I guess to say like there's Matt
and Elektra in daredevil season 2
there's Jessica and if you guys haven't
seen season 2 if I told you who it was
it ruined a big part of the show but
there's an equality there in Luke Cage
Luke and Bushmaster and now here you got
Danny and Davos D&D daredevil what it's
all - there was a line in here that I
found a little interesting word you know
it's kind of a cliche line for these
heroes who say if it has to be peace
I've seen this season one once and I've
only seen the defenders one time but I
thought it's like a thing he is the
voluntary position the way he says that
there sounds like he was strictly chosen
for a destiny he didn't ask for but I
thought I thought it was a mantle he has
to work as
up to achieving so I don't know why he'd
be saying that especially since he loves
to gloat that he's the immortal Iron
Fist I hope by the end of the show
iron fist gets the official Iron Fist
suit I mean they're teasing it when he's
at Kong long but that is obviously a
flashback but I would love it if he
could have the suit kind of what they
did with daredevil season 1 if he could
have an official Iron Fist suit yeah
overall this looks a lot more personal
the action looks a lot better I'm
excited for misty night and Colleen wing
to be pairing up here Davos is the
villain I think it's a really good
choice either way even if this season
isn't great it looks like it's gonna be
better than season 1 so and it's not
really that high his bar set by the
Marvel Netflix shows I'm looking forward
to this September 7th okay I'm looking
forward to this all right guys well
thanks for watching are you guys excited
for iron fist season 2 or are you just
really anticipating the season 3 trailer
for daredevil like I am you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation please
click that notification belkin subscribe
buttons don't really do the job anymore
and you can check us out on patreon we
got full-length TV show reactions weekly
Q&A s and music video coverage would
love to have you become a page from
eject
[Music]